well nascar will be in town on september
24th but this weekend at hash house of
gogo you can get up close and personal
with one of the top cars i stopped by
the restaurant for all the details
check this out it's the smithfield
number 10 ford mustang and not only this
weekend can you get a cool photo with
the car here at hash house at gogo you
can test your driving skills they have a
nascar simulator i'll get to that in a
second this is brandon with hash house
we've got the car we've got the
simulator and one other thing this
weekend what are you doing you can win
nascar tickets
with pit passes it passes too now you
here at hash house you have a nice
connection with smithfield we do we've
partnered with smithfield we've done all
of our bacon pork products we got the
bacon bacon bacon the blt sandwich of
course the bacon lettuce tomato bloody
mary
and then your your breakfast because if
you're gonna do a nascar simulator i
think a hash house bloody mary is the
perfect thing to have before you get
behind the wheel absolutely why not
let's go let's go check out this similar
this is so cool so it's real simple
you're gonna be at the west charleston
location tonight tonight five to eight
and this is all free get free photos do
the nascar simulator for free and it's
so easy and so much fun just roll inside
the uh the smithfield hauling cars what
this is right yes it is pop in your seat
all right you're my uh
coach right
backseat driver maxi driver and uh step
on the gas to start
wow put it in first gear
and we're all
second gear
now what's so cool about this is this is
actually las vegas motor speedway that
you're racing at the actual track
i feel the steering while vibrating now
oh boy so it's getting a little loose on
me
brandon is gonna be at the west
charleston location tonight until eight
o'clock five to eight
we'll be out at west charleston the
summerlin location of the old islands
come join us this is so much fun again
it's free you guys uh i'm gonna finish
the race and then what are you going on
what are you when i go go get some food
perfect
a lot of fun that nascar simulator so
it'll be at the west charleston location
tonight and tomorrow night from five to
eight and the west sahara house
restaurant tomorrow morning that's
perfect and bloody mary's because it's a
simulator yes bloody mary's yeah bloody
mary's are great it's similar that's why
you can have a bloody mary i think
that's perfect a couple all right